hi Samuel leaves here and in this video
I want to explain exactly what to do if
you've got so many different property
deals coming your way that you don't
even know which one to choose if that's
you then stay tuned if it's not it will
be one day so stay tuned anyway so
people just say they've got too many
deals to choose from that either lying
to look really cool or they genuinely
have got so many deals to choose from if
they really have got too many deals to
choose from they're either going to be
starting out and they've only got a
little bit of money they don't know
where to put it or they've been going
for a while and they're just getting
deal after deal after deal and I can't
keep up with the finance of it and it's
like I mean you know you can't buy
everything good so let me address both
if you're the first person if you're the
person who is just starting out and
you've got lots of deals I would just
say just just buy one buy the one that
you feel is the best the one that's
going to give you the best return on
investment because all about what you
put in what you get out so which one's
giving you the best return on investment
which one's making the most money and
then buy that one take your feelings out
of this if your person - where boy
you've been going a while you've got
some good investments you've got some
good experience and you're just finding
loads and loads of good deals firstly
congratulations that's a brilliant
problem to have what I would suggest is
if that's you then that's maybe it's
time to start thinking about raising
finance maybe it's time to start
thinking about joint venture Inc and
maybe it's time to start thinking about
deal sourcing and packaging for other
investors so what do I mean by that well
let's say you've got ten properties
already you're looking for an 11th but
then you find another five and it's like
oh my gosh which one do I buy well buy
one and then with the other four what
you gonna do you can either just let
them go down the drain or you can still
make money on them in order to make
money on a property deal that you can't
finance you could borrow money from
somebody else and then pay them say 10
percent or whatever and then buy the
property and then if you're making 20 30
% but you're paying them 10 and let it
even have a stake in the property you're
winning number two you can joint then so
you can find somebody who's got the
money but you've got the experience and
the expertise and you say let's team up
you put the money in I'll put my
expertise in we go 50/50 on the profits
or number three which is the easiest and
the fastest way to earn quick cash
I love it which is deal source Inc
that's when you you take the opportunity
you negotiate the price you package up
and then you pass it on to an investor
you marry up a good investment to a good
invest door and you charge a fee in the
middle last year we married up 136 deals
with property investors a niche deal was
giving us a fee of maybe two three four
thousand pound you can do the math you
can make pretty good money deal sourcing
there are you know you do need to be
good you doing what you're doing you
need to be compliant but it's definitely
something I'd consider if you're finding
lots of deals so don't stop keep doing
what you're doing and if you're
struggling getting your first deal then
just stay focused don't worry about all
this stuff but anyway check out the rest
of my videos I hope you find them useful
please do comment share subscribe like
and I hope to meet you in person one day
god bless thank you so much for watching
if you benefited on that video please do
share it with your family and friends
for more videos like it you can watch
right here and if you'd like to spend
two days with me at the property
investors crash course watch this video
see what happens but whatever you do
don't forget to subscribe right here and
I'll see you next time